okay here we go I hope you're ready for
this I hope I'm ready for this
I once spoke to my supervisor in
religious studies about a banana bee and
that I was having some trouble
understanding his ideas and he comforted
me by saying that anyone who claims to
understand a banana bee is either wrong
or they're lying to you so clearly we
are here dealing with a very difficult
figure perhaps one of the most difficult
thinkers in all of Islamic history if
not history generally but since this is
one of my main fields of interest in the
study I will try to give you a sort of
short simple introduction to this
massive figure in Muslim history so
let's talk about a banana bee
[Music]
Abdullah Mohammed Ben Ali eben Mohammed
they've been Arabi I'll had to me a tie
or more commonly known simply as even
our abhi was a Sufi mystic poet and
philosopher in the broad sense of that
term that has had a massive impact on
the Islamic intellectual tradition to
some he is a very divisive and
controversial figure to those who admire
him and follow him is known as sheikh al
akbar or the greatest master and so the
view doesn't one of the greatest Saints
in all of Islamic history and to others
he's a dangerous heretic as will become
clear both of these positions stem from
his very unique fascinating and
complicated metaphysical and
cosmological ideas the basis of which is
often called what at illusion which
means the unity of a being and this is a
doctrine that we were turn to soon but
these ideas have cemented him as one of
the most important and interesting
thinkers and figures in all of history
if not abhi was born in the year 11 65
in the city Marcia in what is today
Spain what we call Spain and Portugal
today was known back then as al-andalus
and was in the 12th century a vibrant
time of intellectual and mystical
activity empanada B was born into a
rather wealthy aristocratic family his
father actually working for the local
Sultan in the city and also among other
things being close friends with the very
famous philosopher even rushed or
averroes Hui banana B would later have a
very famous encounter with for the most
part however empanada B grew up in the
city's severe since his family moved
there when he was very young he would be
educated as was fitting for someone of
his status and he would take part in the
vibrant cultural life of the city at the
time al-andalus was at a time ruled by
the Almohad dynasty which can be seen as
a rather puritanical and strict
interpretation and in terms of its
social and religious policies but in
spite of this the region was ripe with
intellectual activity of all sorts
banana bees youth and in the time before
al-andalus and North Africa had been
blessed with many famous thinkers and
philosophers like a band rush that I
mentioned even to fail even Bahji the
Jewish philosopher Maimonides and Sufis
like Abba Madonna and eben bana John who
were both predecessors of a banana B he
would greatly influence him in fact in
his youth a banana B would most likely
have been exposed and influenced by many
of these currents even if he didn't
receive any extensive education and
philosophy or fanciful faults of a
tradition for example nonetheless he
lived a life for the first part of his
life that could be described as a rather
worldly which would have been rather
common for someone of his status at the
time but sometime in his teenage years
he would have an experience that changed
his life forever it is said that a
banana bee was at a dinner party at
which wine was being served and just as
a banana he was raising his glass to
drink from it he heard a voice that said
to him Muhammad which was his first name
it was not for this that you were
created and this crisis and which he
fled from the party and went to the
Graveyard in Sevilla where he meditated
some say for several days or even weeks
it was during this time of meditation
that he had his first major spiritual
vision and received what he calls fad or
illumination or opening in which all the
sciences and secrets he would later
convey in his teachings were revealed to
him all at the same time and on the same
time he also claims that he had a vision
of the prophets Moses Jesus and Mohammed
who all encouraged him to follow the
religious or spiritual path indeed Jesus
was especially important to him and not
to be in this regard and he refers to
Jesus as his first teacher and the one
who inspired him to his leader
asceticism these visions and experiences
would lead empanada me to give away all
of his belongings and dedicate himself
to a ascetic life on the Sufi path now
even though he considered himself to be
kind of above most Sufi masters since he
had already received all the secrets and
all the knowledge in this one
grand vision he would still dedicate
himself and study under various masters
and sheiks in al-andalus Claude Addis in
his excellent biography of the Sheikh
called quest for the red sulphur writes
quote in a sense if inaudible arrived at
the goal of spiritual realization
straightaway following the example of
the motto the ecstatics he burned all
the stages and in one single leap
completed the journey of the quest but
that he was quote obliged to make the
journey again step by step to perform
the wayfaring or sir Luke
patiently and entered truly on the way
the Masters are shakes he would frequent
include perhaps above all a quote
illiterate peasant called abul abbas al
arabi but also names like Imran Musa
have an umbrella medulla and actually a
few women like shams of Martina and
Fatima bint Abdal Mehsana
he talks about these masters in his book
or or he'll quotes from Menasha hatun
nafs released in English as Sufis of
Andalusia and the foothill Makia and in
which he says quote I served as a
disciple one of the lovers of God a lady
of Sevilla called Fatima bint a banana
thana of Cordoba I served her for
several years she being over 95 years of
age she used to play on the tambourine
and show great pleasure in it she used
to say to me I am your spiritual mother
and the lights of your earthly mother I
banaji was also especially found on the
North African Sophia boumedienne whom he
considered to be his almost foremost
teacher and the Sufi that he mentions
the most in his own writings even though
that who never actually met in person
even claimed to be taught by wizard the
legendary figure of the Quran that is
said to have been also a teacher of
Moses scholars tend to divide a banana
miss life into two periods the first
part of which he spent in in al-andalus
in the Maghreb in North Africa and the
second part in which he spent in the
East indeed for the first part of his
life he never left his home region and
he would travel across modern Spain
Morocco Algeria and so on visiting
different masters travelling between
cities visiting masters and tombs of
great Saints he would frequently spend
time in these cemeteries meditating or
going on spiritual retreats called
Halawa he continued to live in ascetic
life and he took part in the literary
circles of the region studying both
religious and profane literature and
would actually become quite an
accomplished poet himself as we will see
later
he also took part in debates regarding
the theology or doctrinal theology
column and also philosophy or fanciful
he would also be in contact with
Christian thinkers and Jewish thinkers
and probably the Kabbalah movement but
it would not be threatened most of his
life is surprisingly uninterested in
refuting or accepting any of the ideas
of these theologians of the philosophers
he disagreed with much what the
philosophers and theologians taught but
he also said that much of it contains
truth as well he simply wasn't that
interested in knowledge conveyed through
intellect as such but rather knowledge
through a mystical unveiling or
intuition known as cash if I were to
talk about this much later but this is a
party remember that a but not obviously
philosopher is primarily interested in
knowledge through experience through
tasting and through intuition rather
than like a philosopher through rational
or intellectual debates but this doesn't
deny the fact that a banana be in his
writings and in the language he uses is
still highly influenced and inspired by
the philosophers a good example of a
banana bees very sometimes strange
relationship to the philosophers is this
very famous meeting with a panda douched
known in the West as a biro is it not a
bee tells this story himself that even
ruched had heard about a banana bee and
his great spiritual powers were status
even though a banana be at this time was
likely very young and his teens are very
early adulthood and of course the fact
there being a Bernard were friends with
even none of his father but the story
goes that a banana arrives at a Ben
Rusch place after his invitation and
they greet each other very warmly and
respectfully after which it been rushed
asks a banana be quote what kind of
solution have you found through
illumination and divine inspiration is
it just the same as what we receive from
speculative thought to reach a banana B
replied yeah
and know between the yes and the no
spirits take flight from their matter
and next break away from their bodies
you can do what you will with that quote
he continued to have visions and
illuminating spiritual experiences as he
traveled across North Africa and Spain
in the year 1190 for at the age of 29
and in the city of Tunis in modern
Tunisia a banana be entered what he
calls God's wide earth Allah Allah and
Wassa sometimes also the realm of
symbols manzil dramas or the earth of
reality erotica this can be seen as one
of the highest stages of the spiritual
path as a banana be himself puts it
quote it is only realized by those who
inhabits God's vast earth which contains
both the contingent and the eternal this
is the Earth of God whoever dwells there
has realized true servitude with regard
to God and God joins that person to
himself and that this earth this God
spider earth is quote a super formal
intelligible earth not a sensory earth
one of the foremost scholars of a banana
by today William chidduck explains the
concept as such quote at the highest
stage of self-knowledge the Gnostics
recognize their own nature as the
infinite and never-ending self
disclosures of God in their constant
visions of the forms of self disclosures
they live along with a banana be in
God's wide earth a lot of strange and
very complicated words and concepts here
but this will be at least a little
clearer once we talk about him that I
was actually teachings and ideas but
we'll get there soon when I leave this
for now he was also given another great
vision in 1190 in the city Cordoba where
he witnessed all the prophets and
messengers of God assemble to name him
the so called seal of [ __ ]
sainthood now we should stop here for a
second and talk about the word wali
which is what I and many others have
here translated as Saint now we should
be careful not to draw too close
parallels to the Christian idea of
saints this is
different but in the Sufi tradition
throughout history there have been many
men and women who have been called by
the name wali which in Arabic literally
means friend and thus denotes a person's
close proximity or intimacy with God
so whenever the Bible talks about the
Hatem allow Lia the seal of the Saints
this is the concept that he's talking
about this could also then be translated
as the seal of the [ __ ] friends as
many of you probably know Muhammad is
known to Muslims as the heart Amanda
being the seal of the prophets which to
the majority of Muslims means that
Muhammad is the last and final prophet
of God but when a banana me considers
himself to be the seal of the saints
were specifically the scene of the
[ __ ] saints he isn't claiming that
he is the last saints or last wali that
would ever exist instead he believes
that every saint is the quote inheritor
of a certain prophet some Saints are so
to say heirs to Jesus or Moses and some
are heirs to Muhammad a banana be viewed
himself as the last saintly complete
heir to Muhammad himself or in the
[ __ ] line of saints and thus
inherits all the knowledge and sciences
Salah say of Muhammad quotes even Arabi
maintains that there are friends of God
in every age and that they will continue
to inherit from Muhammad but they will
no longer have access to the entirety of
Muhammad's works States and Sciences the
modalities of the inheritance will be
defined by their connection to specific
prophets embraced by Muhammad's
all-comprehensive prophethood being the
last inheritor of Muhammad insane turn
is a very privileged position to be
given quote if the Muhammad and Friends
of God inherits all the sciences of
Muhammad this means that they have been
open to all the knowledge and
understanding given to all the prophets
since Muhammad has seen as the
all-comprehensive prophets who contained
the messages of all the previous
prophets thus the seal of the Muhammad
and friends will somehow embody the
whole Quranic message in other words it
not to be thought very highly of himself
and of course even though he considered
those two
been given this position by the prophets
themselves this is a standpoint that has
been criticized by many as being very
well pretentious which is maybe
understandable but this is still a very
important concept to understand in order
to well to understand a banana be and
his worldview when is the view we Adam
himself and his responsibility towards
the larger Muslim community and the
world at large and after spending the
first half of his life in the
environments of al-andalus and the
Maghrib he then decided to leave his
home region and travel to the eastern
parts of the so-called Muslim world and
this is a trip that he would never
return from one of the goals of this
journey was to go on the Hajj pilgrimage
to Mecca which is a duty for every
Muslim time to take at least once in
their life he began by traveling to
Egypt where he stayed in Cairo or Fustat
rule at a time by the a ubud dynasty of
the famous Saladin he then took a detour
through Jerusalem before finally
reaching the hedges and the holy city of
Mecca in the year 1202 his stay in Mecca
which he visited at least twice and they
stayed lasted for three years would be
one of the most significant and
important periods of a banana bees life
it would be the catalyst for some of his
most important literary works it was
here that he met the young woman Nizam
whom he fell hopelessly in love with at
first glance I would inspire him to
write the fantastic poetic work the
Telugu man a lush walk the interpreter
of desires in which his love for a Nizam
serves as a metaphor for love of God it
was also in Mecca that he had another
one of his most major spiritual visions
while which really circulating the Kaaba
and praying he encountered what he calls
a youth who began communicating with him
through metaphors and after a short
profound conversation a banana be
realized who this youth really was he
puts it like this in the introduction to
the photo Hethel Makhija quote suddenly
while I was before the black stone
astonished I came upon the transient
youth the silent speaker the one who is
neither living nor dead
the compass it's simple the encompassed
encompassing him in a secret gesture and
I knew then he tion to me a truth of his
beauty and I was overwhelmed with
passion I was felled before him and the
moments overcame me it seems that the
youth is in some way God himself
communicating with a banana pea but it's
not entirely clear in what way maybe
nada because it's the spirit and the
youth seemed to refer to God as
something other than itself sometimes
but at other times it's much clearer
with the youth referring to himself as
the Lord so it becomes clear that in
some way at least this seems to be God
communicating with the banana be a
banana be then has an ecstatic
experience or vision where he witnesses
basically the entire universe or cosmos
itched into the body of this youth it's
incredible
imagery quote the youth said I am the
mature garden the universal harvest so
lift my veils and recite what is
contained edged in my lines what you
learned from me put it in your book and
speak directly in it to everyone dearest
to you I lifted his valence and I
observed his edged lines and their tion
to my eyes his light that was deposited
on him whatever he contained and
encompassed of hidden knowledge what a
banana be saw edged into the body of
this spirit this youth is what would
become his probably greatest work the
foot too hot and Makia which means the
Meccan the Meccan revelations with the
Meccan openings which is a massive piece
of work that spans over 10,000 pages for
the next couple of years a banana B
would continue to travel around
different regions and cities but this
time in the East instead of the West he
stayed in Konya and Turkey Iraq Egypt
and Palestine among other places he
married and had children and at the same
time had the most productive period of
his life it is during this last period
of his life that he composes the
majority of his written works he
eventually decided to
down in DC to Damascus around the Year
1223 and would stay there for the rest
of his life and from here it would
continue to give spiritual guidance to
students and rights great works of
poetry and prose while at the same time
raising his family even an abbey had
many disciples who would later become
famous in their own right his most
closest or some would say maybe
favorites his disciple was a man by the
name of eibon's saw the Keane who had
accompany banana before basically the
majority of his life another one of his
most prominent students was soldered in
Kunar we who had become his stepson
after he married the young solder Dean's
widowed mother who now he would be
considered his closest students in a way
and one whom he considered like his son
he would be the student that led the
interpretation and dissemination of the
shaykhs work after his death being
responsible for much of our
understanding of it today living mostly
in Konya turkey he also had close ties
with the very famous contemporary Sufi
poet Jalal add-in Rumi which then
indirectly connects two of the most
famous Sufis in history Rumi and
empanada B through his student qunari
there's a good example to show just how
important how close of a student Kaname
was to hit banana B if not other what
often holds audiences or sama where he
would present or read his new texts to
different people and these these
sessions were attended by different
people depending on the nature of the
text so a text that were aimed to a more
larger broader general audience would be
attended by a lot of people his students
and maybe general audiences as well
while other more difficult or complex
works would be attended on only by a
chosen few those who were his closest
and most involved students now in 1233
he held one of these sessions for his
one of his last and maybe his crowning
work which is a book called the faso
cell he come the ring stones of wisdom
and very interestingly at this session
where he read this book only soldered in
Kaname was present other students or
acquaintances also include controversial
figures like a FIFA dental M Sonny who
had ties to another controversial Sufi
philosopher called eben Sabine
who
can and probably will dedicate a whole
other video to nonetheless after a long
life of great activity traveling across
the Muslim lands writing a bunch of
works and teaching many students on the
spiritual path even now be probably left
this world on November 8th 12:40 having
reached the age of 75 the life of a
banana B is of course a very interesting
tale filled with fascinating stories and
what is perhaps most significant about
him is after all what he said what he
taught and what he wrote and what his
ideas were he wrote many different where
he decided he wrote hundreds of
different works of varying lengths and
contents some of the most famous of
which I've already mentioned like the
food to hath and makea the Meccan
revelations or mekin openings which is
this massive work of 10,000 pages that
basically goes goes through everything
like it's an encyclopaedia of this
entire thought there is the very famous
paretic work the Tarot zoom on the ash
walk the interpreter of desires in which
what's been spired by the beautiful
Nizam in Mecca he order also about the
raw help woods or the Sufis of Andalusia
in English translation in which he tells
these stories about the great Sufis of
the Western tradition in London Lewis
and maghrib and lastly the foo sous al
hakam which to some is his crowning work
and in which he presents his
metaphysical ideas in full and sometimes
shocking force but what do these texts
actually say what are the ideas and
teachings of a banana bee that is both
so controversial and so loved at the
same time this is what we will talk
about in part 2
okay so empanada B's metaphysics and
cosmology is a very broad and
complicated subject but it's impossible
for me to fit it into one video but he
is associated with a doctrinal idea
that's referred to as what dot world or
the unity of being and is this
philosophy that is followers to this day
CSD culmination and utmost expression of
monotheism while those who are skeptical
of him see it as a complete heresy that
was important to remember is that a
banana by himself never uses the word
what attitude the unity of being but
this is a name or a term that was used
by later thinkers and was applied to him
but this isn't to say that the ideas
that we mean when we say what that I
would you it doesn't apply to Nana B
because in his writings he often of
course seems to imply a lot of these
ideas even so I banana B is notoriously
difficult of a writer who rarely speaks
in clear terms he isn't the philosopher
in the traditional sense of that term in
that he doesn't present this argument
through his ideas as rational arguments
or as a systematic presentation rather
it is structured as visions and
illumination spiritual experiences
basically that he retells therefore when
we interpret them in a B we are often
relying on later interpreters later
writers who have formulated his ideas
into a more systematic form chief among
these of course is soldering clue now is
close a student that I mentioned earlier
who now he is very much responsible for
systematizing anonymous ideas into a
more coherent philosophical language we
aren't exactly sure whatever not be
meant a lot of the time my point is that
it's important to remember that we are
relying on outside commentators and it's
always open to interpretation how these
ideas should be understood and I will be
relying on outside interpretations later
commentators in my presentation of the
unity of being as such in short terms
the adoption of the unity of being is
based on taking monotheism to its
most extreme and it not only states that
God is the only divinity in existence he
is the only being in existence one of
God's so-called 99 names in the Quran is
al Haq which means the truth or the real
or the reality with this in mind the
Islamic Proclamation la ilaha illallah
isn't simply read as there is no god but
God or there is no divinity but the
divinity but instead as there is no
reality but the real or thus ultimately
there is nothing but God to a banana bee
and his followers there is only one
singular reality and that reality is God
a banana B identifies God in his utmost
essence as wizard or being or existence
so God is being he isn't a being he is
being itself and since Islamic theology
requires that God not only be the only
divinity but also that he is absolutely
one that must necessarily mean that
being or existence itself is one
absolutely one this also means that if
anyone says that anything exists except
of God one is actually committing
shidduch or polytheism which is the
greatest sin in Islam since you are
saying that there is a being that isn't
God but being is God and that basically
means you're saying that there is
another God but if God is the only
reality what are we what is creation
there appears to be
multiplicity everywhere what what's that
- a banana be anything other than God
which is creation basically is utterly
non-existent it's a kind of illusion
he writes quotes the world is illusory
and has no real existence this is what
is meant by imagination hi al you have
been made to imagine that the world is
something separate and independently
real outside of the absolute but in
reality this is not so but it isn't an
illusion in the ultimate sense we do
have a certain existence on the physical
plane it's not all a dream like in
Advaita Vedanta and Hindu
for example the illusion is the idea of
separation that I exist as a separate
being when in reality only God exists
the only true self is God's self and
ours are only relative reflections of
this self one of the more celebrated
scholars from Abu Dhabi schools Muhammad
shall be story or a masterpiece of
Persian poetry called the Gulshan or oz
in which he xpick AIT's the doctrine of
the unity of being and he writes quote
when absolute existence is alluded to
people use the word i as a matter of
expression when reality has taken form
through individuation you refer to it in
language with the word i you and i are
accidents of the essence of being like
openings and the covering of the lamp of
being a banana be himself loves to use
metaphors to describe this relationship
between God in the world one of them is
where he describes it almost like a
light a pure white light which is God's
being that travels through a prism and
creates a multitude of colors which
would be the world the colors themselves
are never the same as the white light
just as the creatures or creation is
never the same as God but at the same
time they consist of nothing but the
white light he also describes the world
as the shadow of God being at once the
same as him and exactly that which is
not him quote we say know that what one
calls other than the real and which is
referred to as the world is in relation
to the real as a shadow is to an object
it is the shadow of God it isn't just
this way that existence is attributed to
the world for without doubt the shadow
is existent in the sensory domain albeit
only when there is something where in
the shadow is manifest it but not often
operates within paradoxes there is
nothing but God but we as creatures are
also absolutely not God we are he and
not he in Arabic who wa lahu wa there's
a metaphor to describe this idea that I
really like personally which comes from
the author robert abdullah hired are in
his introduction to the translation of
muhammad shah be study there he
describes the God world relationship
through these
of a projector imagine a projector
projecting a movie or image onto a wall
the light from the projector is being or
God's reality with God the wall on which
it projects is non-existence it's non
being nothingness it is in the meeting
of absolute being and nothingness that
the created world operates as an isthmus
a line in between the two extremes we as
in creation are the images themselves
formed by the light which despite taking
different forms remain one and undivided
it is the nothingness that obscures that
light that create the forms but the
light itself remains unchanged faculity
Nawrocki another famous writer in the
even Anna B school writes the following
in his book Lama at quote come then into
my eyes and look and you will see a sun
shining through a thousand bits of glass
beaming to plain sight through each
array of color why should any difference
appear between this one and that all
light is one but colors a thousandfold
if you've read Hindu philosophy or
Taoism or Christian mystics like Meister
Eckhart Allah this will seem very
familiar to you in fact the doctrine of
the unity of being sometimes bears a
striking resemblance to philosophies
like Advaita Vedanta or certain ideas
within Taoism for example among many
other things there are differences of
course but they share aspects explained
thus far with a single absolute non dual
reality being identified with God and
denying the reality of anything beside
him but what creates the forms of the
world themselves what is the world when
it is not pure being and where does
multiplicity come from it will help a
bit to try to look at things like the
people back then would have viewed the
world partly thanks to a benzina or
Avicenna philosophically one had at this
time started to separate between
existence or being assured on the one
hand and essence or what 'no SMAW here
on the other when talking about a thing
or an object in the
like this table in front of me we can
ask two basic questions about it we can
ask is it and we can ask what is it the
first question is it is a question of
existence or being and the answer to
that question would be yes or no the
second question what is it gives a
completely different answer and this is
the question of essence or what Ness in
this case a table table is independent
of whether or not it exists it is an
essence or what Ness that can either
exist or not exist it can either have
existence or which would being or it can
have we can not have existence or being
so according to what a turtle was you
would in terms of the existence or the
being the was you would of the objects
of the world they are God because
remember God is being he is being itself
is the only being and so God is thus our
being
he is our being however in terms of our
essences are what nasai are absolutely
not God we are that which by definition
God isn't I as a human being feel at
home cannot possibly be God because I am
everything that God isn't I am I am
finite I am temporal I am mortal I have
a certain form these are all things that
God cannot possibly be because this
would limit God and God is limitless God
is eternal God is perfect God is
immortal and all these things so this is
the relationship that we have here we
are simultaneously God and not God we
are absolute existence and we are
absolute non-existence we are being and
non-being all at the same time but it
doesn't end here these essences or what
misses also has a relationship with God
even if they aren't God directly here we
will need to have some basic knowledge
of Islamic theology again so according
to mainstream islamic theology God is
absolutely transcendent beyond any
creaturely qualities so he doesn't have
any attributes or qualities that any
created things or creatures have but
according to the Quran and mainstream
Islamic theology he still has certain
attributes and each of his name's like a
hawk or rahman al rahim and so on all
these names that he's referred to by
corresponds to a search
attribute that he has so al-haqq means
the truth or the real he is the real he
is the truth a Rahman means the merciful
he's merciful Rob means the Lord for
some all these names that he has is also
an attribute that he has now
traditionally in the Quran it is said
that God has 99 names and there's also
99 attributes but according to a banana
be the names are actually infinite he
has an infinite amount of names and an
infinite amount of attributes and
qualities and these attributes and
qualities have a very important role to
play in creation interestingly there is
an idea that I banoffee expresses where
God can be viewed in two different ways
there is firstly God as the essence or a
VAT and this is the absolute ultimate
reality and identity of God where there
are no attributes and nothing at all can
be said or understood or grasped about
God the extent of which we can say about
him in this state is that he is and
beyond that language completely fails us
the attributes that we talk about are
there in a sense but they are not
attributes as such but just parts of
this unknowable essence in some
mysterious way or not part of there but
they are this essence the attributes are
not distinguished there's just this one
essence that is completely unknowable
then there is God as he relates to the
world the God with attributes like
merciful or as creator and Lord and this
is the form of God that most people
think of when we talk about God but this
is not the ultimate form of God the
essence is so the attributes in this
sense are dependent on creation the
attributes like merciful creator are
only relationships to us as creatures
and don't exist in the essence in that
same way instead they could be seen as
to simply point to be which you see them
may be as metaphors that point to
certain realities within this one
essence and this idea is obviously very
similar to the idea expressed by Adi
Shankara and advaita vedanta about near
guna brahman on the one hand and saguna
brahman on the other oh this is almost
identical to even Allah beside the in
fact
there's a hadith Qudsi a saying of the
Prophet Muhammad where God is speaking
through him in which God says I was a
hidden treasure and I loved to be known
so I created the world so that I might
be known he gotta be loves this hadith
as he used it frequently it is the key
to understanding creation and the
purpose behind it I was a hidden
treasure refers to God's essence and the
attributes that are hidden therein I
loved to be known he wants to he wants
this hidden treasure to be experienced
and of course he knows his own
attributes since he well he is he but he
still wants his essence and attributes
to be experienced through someone who is
not him so I created the world so that I
might be known therefore the world is
created as a way for God to experience
himself through someone other than
himself there's a great section nifa
suzana come where he talks about this
relationship as a person who is talking
about himself so if I refer to myself
and say something like I really love
coffee which I usually don't but it's
let's say I say this in saying I really
like coffee there is a duality created
there between the one who is speaking
and the one I am speaking of I'm
speaking about myself even though it's
essentially really the same person
speaking about himself so this is the
kind of relationship the world has to
God it is different from God there is a
duality created between the Lord the
creator and creation but ultimately
creation is simply God that is
experiencing himself but since this
hidden treasure is to be known through
the world that must mean that the world
contains traces of these attributes and
qualities of God right this is
absolutely true - banana be the world is
nothing but to use William jeddaks words
the loci of God's self-disclosure or
God's self manifestation so everything
in the world every essence in
philosophical terms every particle of
this world reflect and reveal God's
qualities and attributes in an indirect
sense like in a mirror this is based
partly on a Quranic verse that I
bunnelby
loves to apply which goes whichever way
you turn there is the face of God now
remember the things of the world or
creation itself is not God he is
absolutely transcendent of them but in a
real sense they reflect everything in
the world the entire cosmos reflects
God's attributes and thus they are God
in a sense - in any case since God is
infinite and so are the possibilities of
his attributes there is no end to the
constant self manifestation of God in
the world at every moment at every
instant the world is created anew
revealing a new self disclosure the
world in that sense becomes the
continuous unfolding of God's
manifestation in limited form
it's the unfolding of possibilities
inherent in actuality the essences of
the world the things are contained in
God's knowledge beyond time and space as
something he calls the Ayana thar beta
the immutable entities these are non
existent in themselves but function
almost as archetypes that determine what
is created in the actual cosmos and
these I Anitha beta are themselves
determined by God's attributes as they
in their totality reflect him so God has
these attributes of qualities and then
he has a knowledge of his own attributes
or qualities which are infinite so
there's an infinite number of
possibilities an infinite number of ways
that his attributes can be manifested
and all these ways all these forms in
which he can manifest himself are
contained in his own knowledge beyond
time and after which when he wants to
create something he simply gives those
archetypes those iana Thabeet a-- he
gives them being and at each instant is
a new creation at East instant is a new
reflection of God that's constantly
unfolding before our eyes so the world
relates to God in two ways on the one
hand there is only one reality the
reality of being and God's essence who
are identical and this is the hidden and
unfathomable aspect of God that we
cannot experience or see or hear in any
way or experience in any way
except through God himself only God
Himself can experience himself in his
own essence on the other hand the things
in the world are reflections of God's
attributes and qualities they aren't God
directly but they reflect him like in a
mirror and receive his being like
containers almost this is the manifest
and apparent aspect of God which we
experience at every moment even if we
don't realize it so let's return to that
projector again as I said the light
itself is being existence it's God
himself it's God's essence the wall on
which it is being projected is
nothingness on which being is being
projected the images that we see on the
wall that is the world that is creation
in ourselves but these images are
created by the light traveling through
pieces of film which delimits and shape
this light into these certain images
this film or the Ayana Thabit ah the
immutable entities that are reflections
of God's attributes so we have a
situation here where from one
perspective there is only light and
different nuances of that light but on
the other hand there are images on the
wall which are determined by this light
being dimmed or shaped into certain
forms which makes them different from
the light because what makes them what
they are is by definition that which is
not the light but at the same time these
images are also determined by the
attributes that are contained within the
light itself I know this is a whole lot
to take in and you may have to watch
this a few times if you this is all new
to you but believe it or not that is
actually the basic very basic simple
explanation of the deduction of what a
Telugu jeweled it is you could see a non
dual philosophy where reality is
ultimately oneness and nothing exists
except for God he is all of being and he
is the one in whose being my being
resides but there are many other nuances
to it that make it a lot more
complicated as I hope I have shown you
some scholars Western scholars
especially in the past
for a banana be as a pantheist or a
pantheist
and of course what this is
understandable it really isn't that
accurate at least from the traditional
prosperity traditional understanding of
the word pantheism now if not abhi does
in a way affirm that the world is God
since there is nothing but God but at
the same time he's very careful to point
out that the world is happened at the
same time absolutely not God and that
God completely transcends the world in
fact the world is as I've said the very
definition of what God isn't in terms of
itself the world is absolute nothingness
non being who has quote never smelled a
whiff of existence this point is finally
expressed by the 19th century figure
Amira birth Khadija xiety famous for his
defense against French colonialism who
was also a follower of banana beyond his
school he states quote I am two things
according to two different relations
with respect to you I am the eternal for
ever and ever
I am the necessary being who epitomizes
himself with respect to me I am pure non
being who has never breathed the perfume
of existence the adventitious being who
remains non-existent in his adventitious
Ness if not I be himself also talks
about this paradoxical situation through
the terms Tennessee and Tash B or
similarity and difference as I mentioned
the cosmos is who wa lahu wa it's he and
not he God is simultaneously the same
and utterly different in every way in
the fossil he come he talks about the
situation how one needs to see the world
through both eyes of reason and
intuition reason tells us that God is
transcendent
while intuition or illumination lets us
know that he's infinitely imminent at
the same time quote if you profess
transcendence tensive you delimit if you
profess imminence - be you restrict but
if you profess both you have been shown
the right way you are a leader in the
Gnostic Sciences a master in other words
if you look at say a rock and say this
is not God he
beyond compare you are qualifying God
and thus in a way limiting him but if
you say this rock is God you are also
limiting him to this rock in particular
which is equally false instead he urges
us to see it as both at the same time
God is always present and he is always
not present whatever we look it is
always God but also never really God
quote do not look to the real while
divesting him of creation and look to
creation clothing it with art but the
real make him incomparable and make him
similar and reside in the seed of
sincerity be thou in union if you wish
or if you wish in distinction through
both obtain a great success this leads
us to another concept which is sometimes
referred to as the divinity of beliefs
as I mentioned earlier banana be wasn't
just a prose writer who wrote
complicated metaphysical works he was
also a very accomplished poet and one of
his most famous poem is probably the
most famous that's always quoted when
when people talk about a banana B is a
poem from the collection that tells Uman
an ash walk the interpreter of desires
that I mentioned earlier this poem has
been recited numerous times because of
its incredible beauty and goes like this
o marvel our garden amidst the flames my
heart has become capable of every form
it is a pasture for gazelles and a
covenant for Christian monks and a
temple for idols and the pilgrims Kaaba
and the tables of the Torah and the
books of the Quran I follow the religion
of love wherever way loves camels take
that is my religion and my faith this
may appear like an expression of
religious tolerance or pluralism which
it really isn't in fact instead it's a
natural extension of a banana bees
metaphysics since the world is God's
manifestation and the place of his
so-called self disclosure that must mean
that whatever we worship we are
worshipping God right quote not attach
yourself to any particular Creed
exclusively so that you disbelieve all
the rest otherwise you will lose much
good now you will fail to recognize the
real truth
of the matter let your soul be capable
of embracing all forms of belief God the
omnipresent and omnipotent is not
limited to any one creed is he saying
that all beliefs and therefore all
religions are equally valid in short
terms no he isn't
he is saying that whatever it is you
believe about God it is right in a sense
because God is all there is and
everything in the world is a reflection
and manifestation of God whatever you
worship be it Jesus on the cross an idol
or a rock it is ultimately all God so
you are right in your worship in that
sense however banana B is of course a
Muslim and a very staunch one he
believes that Islam is the one true
religion and the discussion where the
people worshipping Jesus or a rock go
wrong is that they are limiting God to
that specific form yes God is the rock
and yes God is Jesus in the statue but
only in the sense that they are
manifestations of him God is much bigger
and more transcendent than that so a
banana B everyone is actually just
worshiping themselves and forms their
perception of God according to their own
natures quotes one only believes in a
divinity through what he has made within
his own soul in other words one
experiences the divine according to
one's own nature or one's own soul we
create an image of God in our own heads
and then we worship that image that
image that we have of God and while in
one sense we are correct in that worship
what we are really doing is only
worshipping ourselves and our own mental
creations this critique also extends to
his fellow Muslims as he sees many of
them or maybe most of them as being
idolaters sure they don't worship a rock
or an actual Idol made of stone but they
still create this image of what God is
in their head and then they worship that
God and this to him is also a form of
idolatry in this discussion he uses a
saying by an older Sufi thinker by the
name of John IDE who said that the water
takes on the color of the cup and this
is true of people's experience or
perception of God God manifest or
discloses himself to
according to their own receptivity or
their own preparedness so everyone
experiences God differently according to
as I said their nature the person who
recognizes that all these images are God
but that he simultaneously transcends
all of them that person is truly
illuminated he will be able to see every
image as God that every moment whatever
way we turn there is the infinite
self-disclosure of God
thus the famous poem now makes a lot
more sense it's speaking from the point
of view of a master Gnostic who has
reached the furthest station on the
spiritual path whatever now because the
station of no station here one soul or
heart is in constant flux realizing that
it is only the eternal reflection of God
which is infinite this soul or heart can
take on any form it can see God in every
form whether it be the pasture for the
gazelles the cloister for the monks or
the pages of the Quran one is not bound
to witnessing God in any one of these
forms instead one follows the religion
of love the innermost cause of creation
and in which everything expresses God's
love of creation and vice-versa
creations love for God so as I mentioned
earlier the entire cosmos is a
manifestation a reflection of the
entirety of God's names or the entirety
of God's attributes while a certain
object in the world or a certain thing
on reflects one or a certain combination
of certain attributes or names the
entire cosmos reflects all of the names
so the creation as a whole is a direct
reflection of God's entire nature his
all of his attributes the cosmos is thus
often referred to by Menotomy as the
macrocosm or the great man in san al
kabir but the human being also has a
central role to play in the scheme and
he is often referred to as the microcosm
or the small man in san elsewhere the
human being thus also reflects all the
names and all the attributes but in a
contained form so the human being is a
microcosmic reflection of the
macrocosm that is the entire universe
and so everything that exists on the
inside access exists on the outside as
above so below and and and so on
thus the human being has a very central
role to play in creation you could say
that he is even the purpose of creation
itself as he he is the only place except
for the in the cosmos in its entire e
where all of the names and attributes
are reflected so we reflect all of God's
attributes and thus he completes the
hidden treasures wanting to be known
from the famous hadith that I quoted
earlier in fact the very first lions of
the facade had come is the following
quote the real will the glorified be he
in virtue of his beautiful names which
are innumerable to see their identities
if he saw where she can say to see his
identity in a comprehensive being that
comprises the whole affair insofar as it
is possessed of existence and his
mystery is manifest to himself through
it this talks about the obviously
creation of the human being and states
that it is the culmination of God's
wanting to know himself through the form
of another man in his most perfect and
primordial form is known as in sand and
camel or the perfect or universal man
this term and concept is one of the most
central aspects of a banana bees thought
arguably maybe the most central in Sanel
camel is a designation of God's perfect
manifestation in human form a human
being who has reached a state of
complete self annihilation where he
recognizes himself as nothing but God's
reflection and acts accordingly in the
perfect man God is finally able to
witness and glorify himself like in a
mirror one of the more famous writers
and poets from the school of a banana be
is a man by the name of [ __ ] Adina
Araki who wrote a incredible piece of
was a combination of prose and poetry
called LaMotte which means divine
flashes and in this book he presents
this relationship between God and the
world through a triad of love lover and
beloved which is a rather common theme
within Sufi and poetry
now love can be seen as the utmost
essence of God being itself and lover
and beloved are the relationship between
the human being and God as he is
experienced by the human being man is
the lover who longs for his beloved
which is God and they gaze upon each
other like in in a mirror in mirrors so
in a sense God sees his own reflection
in the mirror of the human being and the
human being sees his own reflection in
the mirror of God and these two these
lovers want desperately to be close to
each other they want to unite with each
other and so the human being cleans this
mirror of his heart so that it more and
more can reflect more perfectly God's
own reflection and when this process is
finally finished and reaches its
culmination the two are finally United
and they reflect each other perfectly
and in this meeting they realized that
the difference between lover and beloved
was only really an illusion and the only
thing that ever existed was the reality
of love itself which is identical with
God's essence of that or being itself as
such then the eye of certainty opens and
staring inwardly at himself he finds
himself lost vanished but he finds the
friend and when he looks still deeper
realizes the friend is himself he
exclaims beloved I sought your hair and
there asked for news of you from all I
met then I saw you through myself and
found we were identical
now I blush to think I ever searched for
science of you the term insanity common
could also be used to refer to the
cosmos at large in a way and it
functions in a similar way but the human
being as you can see has a very special
position in a banana bees cosmology and
this description by Araki is the actual
practice or the unit of the practical
psychological aspects of Sufism or a
banana bees thought as well a banana me
was of course a Sufi and so he would
practice the most common Sufi practices
like a vicar remembrance where the names
of God were certain
you could say mantras almost certain
terms are repeated over and over again
and similar to many other Sufis the goal
of these while these Sufi practices or
the goal of life in general is to fight
against your nafs your ego or your lower
self and finally reach a unity or you to
unite with God but to a banana bee and
many other Sufis there is never any
uniting with God this would actually be
an impossibility since that would mean
that's there was an imperfection in God
if something can be added to him
non-existence can never unite with
absolute being this is just an
impossibility instead if not it puts a
lot of emphasis on self-knowledge since
these the human being in the self is a
direct reflection of God as everything
else is the key to suicide enlightenment
is actually to know yourself to gain
knowledge of your own self there's a
hadith where the Prophet Muhammad is
thought to have said know yourself and
you shall know your Lord thus the goal
is to realize that one's own separate
existence is a kind of illusion as we
are only the continuous self
manifestations of God thus to know
ourselves and to know our soul in a
proper way is to know God but this can
only be achieved through the right kinds
of knowledge so there's no uniting with
God the part of us that is creature the
part of us that is separate from him can
never unite with him the goal is to
realize that there is nothing but God
and that our being is his being put in
another way
uniting with God is not a process it's a
realization of what what has always been
we don't unite with God we realized that
we in a sense were God all along that
which has United with God is not his
creature such words are not spoken by
the completed person what is non being
that it should unite with the real and
on on being makes spiritual journey in
progression in Union the fantasy of you
ends only when the other vanishes is
their union don't say the contingent has
transcended its limits it has not become
the necessary nor the necessary it
Union with a real is separation from
creativeness estrangement from oneself
is acquaintance with a real when the
contingent removes the dusts of
contingency except for the necessary
nothing remains there are other aspects
of the insanity camel and these other
ideas that gives me headaches just
thinking about it
so I will not go any further into it but
just know that this is a vast field
right phonebooks
just about these philosophies but this
has believe it not been a very short
introduction to a banana bees general
metaphysical ideas there's a lot more to
it as I said but I could maybe explore
that further in future videos but this
will be sufficient for now while I'm
Anatomy is a very original thinker
obviously these ideas didn't appear just
in a vacuum he is very much dependent
and influenced by other thinkers that
had come before him in his language he
is inspired by the Muslim philosophers
like eben Cena even if he is critical of
them at times thus we find a lot of
traces of Neoplatonism in his thoughts
for example when talking in
philosophical language like in the work
at the haqqani he talks about the
hierarchy of existence in terms of first
intellect universal soul and so on which
are very common Neoplatonic
terms in fact some of his contemporaries
thought that he was so influenced by
this school that he had become known by
some as eben flattened or the son of
Plato and even though he didn't consider
himself a philosopher and he was often
very critical of their rational approach
to theology he still respected many of
them a lot in fact in the photo Hetal
Makia he refers to play dough as
flattened Elahi or the divine play-doh
we can also see traces from more
unlikely places like the Elon Asafa the
brethren of purity who are as Smiley's
some of the more esoteric aspects of his
theoretical mysticism do have direct
parallels in that movement like the
microcosm macrocosm relationship or a
small man versus large man and they're
sort of reflecting each other and so on
since he was a Sufi and belonged to the
Sufi tradition he of course takes a lot
of influence from the previous Sufi
thinkers and from general ideas that had
been
around in that movement as well while he
is often credited with the doctrine of
the unity of being it is clear that
these ideas or similar ideas had been
floating around for a long time
among the Sufis a very good example is
the famous sufi from Baghdad Mansur
al-hallaj who is thought to have entered
ecstasy and exclaimed Ana al-haq I am
the truth where I am the way I was he
was saying I am God and was possibly
executed for it or at least very much
shunned and there are many other
examples Rumi also expresses similar
ideas and lumen was a near contemporary
women RB even if they never met and so
even if he was very important for this
kind of philosophy it is clear that
other Sufis both before and at the same
time as him had similar ideas to us same
ideas what a banana be can be said to
have done is to for the first time
theoretically and in at least somewhat
systematic way formulate a theory and
also to add terms like in sand camel and
other a certain theoretical concepts to
it and of course the creation of a
certain school of followers that came
after him who would hold on to this idea
or his expression of this idea very
strongly in particular some people
scholars included have presented eben
Abbey as being tolerant or pluralistic
and this statement is problematic partly
because it's taken very modern terms and
applying it to someone who lived almost
a thousand years ago but at the same
time he in other cases expresses ideas
that can't really be considered very
tolerant he was as I said a very staunch
Sunni Muslim and he wasn't that fond of
Shiites for example he was also
sometimes highly critical of the
philosophers even though he had very
strong opinions about things and he was
absolutely sure that he was right a
banana bees method of reaching knowledge
was not primarily through reason or
intellect as the philosophers often
would instead he reaches knowledge by
what he refers to as cache which means
unveiling to the kind of
intuitive spiritual knowledge that is
directly experienced they not only
believe that this form of knowledge was
the highest in form but that it should
nonetheless be complemented with reason
and revelation revelatory texts like the
Quran as I've mentioned he asks us to
view the world with both eyes of both
reason and intuition but despite this he
believed that the rational approach to
God that the philosophers were taking
was foolish and would only lead to
confusion they were misguided he would
claim even if some of their ideas are
true and this is where some of that
apparent tolerance actually does come in
he never denies that the philosophers
has good things or true things to say he
affirms that they actually do when
applies much of their terminology and
thinking into his own writings this
includes the schools of theology like
the Asha Knights and the Mata Silla a
banality believes that they all actually
have good things to say and that at this
sometimes one is closer to the truth
than another but that he himself never
subscribes to any one school of thought
in particular it is when it comes to the
ultimate knowledge the knowledge of God
not of things in this world this is
where reason becomes unnecessary or
actually and harmful here when it comes
to this level the only way to reach true
knowledge or proper knowledge is through
cash it's through unveiling so even at
abhi does have a somewhat lenient
attitude towards the philosophers even
though he often disagrees with them he
holds a strong conviction that one
should not engage in fighting about
these matters a good example is a letter
he wrote to the theologian [ __ ] Dean
Razi in which he asks him to abandon his
theology and enter the mystical path
instead in this letter he criticizes the
philosophical approach that Allah Rossi
takes but does so in a very friendly and
sort of almost brotherly manner
similarly another good example of his
approach would be the following which is
from one of his writings quotes it is
best to separate yourself from people
who do not believe in what you believe
who do not do what you do and who are
against your faith yet at the same time
you should not think badly of them or
condemn them for what they are your
intention and ignoring them should be
that you prefer the company
believers this idea of a banana B
so-called tolerance can also be extended
to his general ethical ideas as well he
often claims that God's mercy precedes
his wrath and that mercy is the very
foundation of existence of creation as
such he himself as the heir to Muhammad
and sainthood is also responsible for
spreading or extending that mercy in the
world he even called himself the
unlimited mersa fire the author Claude
adass writes quote he wished to be a
source of hope for all created beings
and they would not be himself writes
quote thanks be to God I am NOT one of
those who love vengeance and Punishment
on the contrary God has created me as a
mercy and has made me an heir to the
mercy of him whom he was said we have
sent you only as a mercy towards the
worlds while he was a staunch Sunni
Muslim with very strong convictions and
calling him tolerant is very
anachronistic and problematic one could
argue that he certainly seems to have
had a very compassionate and relatively
open approach to existence and to
religion in many ways he embodies the
common Sufi ideal that love for God
equals love of his creation and this
becomes even more prominent than his
thoughts since essentially everything is
God and so obviously you must always
want well for something that you love if
you love God help and serve as much as
you can the people who hide their misery
who are content with their poverty the
travelers on the path to truth do not
attribute to yourself virtue goodness
and graciousness because of your service
to the creation consider that you all
other people thanks for having hardly
accepted your help it is a comment upon
you to lighten the load of those who are
burdened if people whose pain you have
helped to alleviate caused you pain in
return if their responses their ways
their habits or a dark and cast shadows
upon you show patience and forbearance
quotes above all what you need is high
morals good character proper behavior
you must identify your bad features and
rid yourself of them your relationship
to whomever you come into contact with
must be based on the best of conduct
but what this means may vary with
conditions and circumstances similarly
in the photos alikom he shows similar
tendencies of compassion and mercy quote
know that kindness for God's slaves
deserves more care than does one zeal
for God or do you not see that God has
made the poll tax and peaceful
co-existence our obligation regarding
the enemies of the religion saying quote
and if they incline to peace
do thou incline to it and put thy trust
in God to a banana bee to care for or
guard God's creatures or other human
beings is to care for or love God
himself so as you can see there is
certainly an argument to be made that
the ethical teachings of a banana bee
could be considered by using modern
terms tolerance since one of his most
important teachings is that we should
extend unlimited love to all of God's
creatures on the other hand which may
surprise some of you a banana bee is
almost fanatically strict when it comes
to following the Sharia or the Islamic
law he's very adamant that his students
and society in general follow the Sharia
as it is laid down by God the Sharia or
Islamic law should here primarily be
seen as the the primary rituals of Islam
like like pray daily prayers and fasting
and the pilgrimage and so on but it also
of course includes the more
legalistically oriented aspects included
in thick or in jurisprudence but here in
terms of v however he is actually a bit
more lenient in certain regards even Ali
was highly critical of the fokaha or
jurists of his day who he felt had
returned the religion into simply a
system of rules and thus neglected its
actual inner reality it's in room
meaning to him differences of opinion
regarding legal matters are a mercy from
God quote God has made the divergence in
legal questions a mercy for his servants
and a broadening of what he has
prescribed they should do to testify
their adoration but in the case of those
who follow the jurists of our time these
jurists have prohibited and restricted
what the Sacred Law had broadened in
their favor they say to the person who
belongs to their school if for example
he is a Hanafy don't go looking for our
Daksha from a Shafi
regarding this problem you are faced
with and so on with all of them this is
one of the greatest calamities and
heaviest constraints in the matter of
religion God himself has said in
religion he has not imposed anything
difficult on you the law has affirmed
the validity of the status of anyone who
makes a personal effort at
interpretation for himself and for those
who follow him but in our day the
jurists have condemned this effort
claiming it encourages people to make a
mockery of religion for them to say this
is the height of ignorance again this
should not be understood as some kind of
liberal standpoint what in the rule of
the law is undermined even a bit is in
fact usually strict that it is observed
but it is a rather unique and more open
perspective on the larger aspects of
jurisprudence based on his understanding
of of mercy as an important aspect of
creation and its role in religion
generally another interesting point is
his legal opinion that women can
actually lead men and mixed
congregations in prayer in the mosque
which is very unusual especially today
but not as unusual as you may think
historically and a banana group
represents one of those people who
considered women to be perfectly capable
of leading men in prayer nonetheless it
would not be both during his life and
especially after became a very
significant and important figure in
Sufism and Islam in general his ideas
like the insanity camel and whatever
Jude would extend a huge influence on
the later traditions his ideas through
Saturday in Kona we and his students
became especially popular in the Persian
world and later also in India where it's
meeting with certain Vedanta traditions
created some very interesting
inter-religious dialogue and discussions
as you may imagine and even if it isn't
as apparent this these doctrines also
very much present in the arabic-speaking
world as well it's no wonder that he is
called the greatest master in most Sufi
context we'll find traces of his
doctrines in India many of the famous
sages and princes like Akbar and Dara
Shikoh were influenced by the unity of
being it most likely influenced Hinduism
and Vedanta through their meeting and
different forms of synthesis as well
through different Muslim saints it also
made its way into things like Sikhism
which appeared in the 15th and 16th
centuries well we shouldn't attribute
too much of this to banana be himself
the ideas of a oneness of reality was
expressed in Sufism and in the Islamic
world before his time as well but we
should recognize that he's a monumental
figure in the history of mysticism
philosophy and human thought in general
he's an incredibly difficult thinker one
that is infinitely fascinating
nonetheless I'll see you next time
[Music]